learning objectives by the end of this
lesson you will be able to describe the
benefits of traditional and agile
approaches to software testing describe
the levels and approaches of software
testing demonstrate a test-driven
development framework with j-unit and
demonstrate a behavior driven
development framework with cucumber
software testing overview software
testing software testing is an
investigation conducted to share
information about the quality of the
product and the service under test to
the organization
the software testing checklist is as
follows is the test meeting the
requirements that guided its design and
development if not there's really no
value using the test the most important
thing about testing is that it ensures
that the behavior of the software under
development meets the requirements of
the business next is the test responding
correctly to the inputs if not either
there is a problem in the test or the
system under test and this needs to be
figured out in remedy it's the test
functioning within an acceptable span of
time or is it running too long and
making the test framework timeout is the
test working properly in its intended
environments be careful it's not unusual
for a test to pass in one environment it
fail in another in order for a test to
be valid it must run reliably in a way
that's appropriate to the environment in
which it is operating
is the test achieving the desired
results in order to make sure that the
test is indeed meeting the desired
results the requirements which the
software is intended to satisfy must be
well known both in terms of
documentation and common knowledge among
the development team tests must be
created according to verifiable
specification not developers assumptions
otherwise a company runs the risk of
spending money developing tests that
have marginal use traditional versus
agile testing let's take a look at
traditional testing first it follows a
predictive model with a step by step
phased approach it certifies the quality
of the product and traditional testing
produces the final system with all the
required features unit testing for each
module is followed by integration and
system testing no feedback is provided
until testing is completed and
modifications are implemented in the
next release agile testing is different
agile testing follows an adaptive model
with an iterative approach it certifies
the quality and fast delivery of the
product even with minimal functionality
each sprint produces a working version
that has a subset of features of the
final system continuous testing and
regression tests are conducted across
all iterations and at the end of every
sprint a short ongoing feedback cycle is
produced and finally modifications are
implemented in the next sprint of the
test cycle the important thing to
understand about traditional testing
versus agile testing is that in agile
continuous testing is a driving
principle testing is conducted
throughout the entire software
development process from development
onto system testing and even after the
code is released many shops take a
test-driven development approach which
is abbreviated as TDD under TDD all
activity emanates from predefined tests
the rule of thumb is are
wireman really is a requirement once its
behavior can be described as a test for
example just saying that a requirement
of the application is that it's easy to
use has marginal value in the TDD world
we need to be able to test for easy to
use designing software under TDD means
that requirements will read something
like the save document feature will be
easy to use this means that a user will
be able to figure out how to save a new
document without prior knowledge in
under three seconds you see how exact
that is taking an agile approach means
that requirements are defined in a way
that is quantifiable and verifiable and
tests written to these requirements can
prove with little or no ambiguity that
the conditions of requirements have been
met
agile testing advantages let's take a
look at some of the advantages of agile
testing
first there's reduced risks a basic
practice of agile is to develop code
iteratively over many Sprint's typically
a sprint will not last longer than four
weeks the benefit of the iterative
approach is that issues are uncovered
quickly and thus resolved quickly
in other words problems appear early are
fixed early this reduces software
development risks significantly when the
development team is following the
waterfall approach one in which problems
keep accumulating until they are
revealed downstream in the QA phase
after development is complete the time
it takes to solve all the problems
presented can become overwhelming so too
can the risks a JAL's iterative approach
breaks development periods into smaller
pieces and thus makes the risks more
manageable also an advantages faster
time-to-market agile iterative approach
not only reduces risks it also allows
features to be released more quickly
from the product backlog users are being
given features in an iterative manner
thus time to market as faster product
testing as a method is a definite
advantage product testing is a part of
all in any activity in the agile process
testing becomes a methodical discipline
that is always performed because QA
personnel are equal members of the
software development team testing is not
a special event delegated to a special
group outside of the development effort
testing becomes a method in the process
overall and is conducted by many people
on the development team easy adaptation
to evolving requirements agile assumes
that change is ever-present in fact
change is welcome
thus the practices that emerge within
the agile process are designed to adapt
to change quickly
for example Sprint's are intended to
occur over a short period of time thus
should change need to be made
businesses don't need to wait for months
to implement a change it can be done as
soon as the next sprint is scheduled to
start and the final advantages improved
quality of products short Sprint's
development processes that are designed
to accommodate you change quickly and
continuous testing throughout the entire
software development lifecycle have the
results of increasing the quality of
products overall implementing small
feature sets means that they can be
tested as the code is created and they
can be fixed quickly should the need
arise
this increases code quality dramatically
advantages of using agile with DevOps
testing let's continue examining the
advantages of using agile with DevOps
testing cohesion of teams small teams
that work closely together day in and
day out create a synergy that
significantly increases productivity as
team members work together closely
during the intensive activity in a
sprint the strengths and weaknesses of
each member
become apparent thus efficient workload
allocation starts to take place
naturally a team member commits to
performing tasks in his or her area of
expertise also he or she will offer to
help others when problems arise no one
person can know it all the team
understands this it's through a
willingness to not only admit ones
weaknesses but also to offer help when
one's expertise is needed that genuine
team cohesion evolves easy scalability
as we've mentioned earlier agile
processes are intended to be flexible
this flexibility makes scaling easier
remember under agile testing is a
continuous activity conducted throughout
all stages of the software development
life cycle also automation is key to
agile continuous automated testing is
easier to scale and a testing process
that's run manually only at release time
flexibility in
combined with automation makes scaling
easy improve quality of products
continuous integration and testing and
process automation are actual features
that provide significant advantages in
DevOps testing as we've mentioned many
times agile iterative development
process along with the use of continuous
automated testing improves the quality
of the software created significantly
testing levels approaches and automation
tools software testing approaches when
it comes to software testing the
important thing remember is that the
role of the software development test
engineer goes well beyond manual testing
in fact and the practice of DevOps the
role of the software development test
engineer is anything but bad of a manual
tester in DevOps manual testing is
frowned upon except in very special
circumstances such as complex
performance testing that requires a very
detailed time sensitive approach to test
preparation the job of the software test
engineer also known as a nested is to
design the automated tests that will be
executed within a continuous integration
continuous deployment framework such as
Jenkins teamcity or Travis CI test
engineers approach testing in a variety
of ways depending on the situation in
terms of determining the quality of
source code the engineer will conduct
the static test a static test is review
of the code and the associated
documentation in order to make sure it
complies with industry standards
regulations and best practices during
static testing the code is not run when
it comes time to run the code dynamic
testing processes are used this might be
a unit test or a more comprehensive
integration test or a system test the
important thing to understand is that
the code is exercised by a test Runner
application such as j-unit the test
Runner exit
runtime testing on the code and reports
the results accordingly there are also
the exploratory and box approaches to
testing which are very closely related
exploratory testing is a term created by
campaigner in 1984
according to caner exploratory testing
is a style of software testing that
emphasizes the personal freedom and
responsibility of the individual tester
to continually optimize the quality of
his or her work by treating test related
learning test design tests execution and
test result interpretation as mutually
supportive activities that run in
parallel throughout the project
it's a learn by doing approach the more
time a test engineer spends with the
testing the more he or she sees
opportunities for improvements and
injustice accordingly box testing is
about defining the degree of visibility
that the tester has to the code and then
determining the scope of testing that
can and should be conducted there's
white box testing which the code is
visible to the testing instrument since
the code is visible it should be
observed and it's behavior under test
needs to be reported in a plaque boxin
the internal code is opaque the testing
instrument has no access to the lines of
code being executed the only information
available is the response from the
component under test a good example of a
blackbox test is testing the server-side
logic of a website or API
unless accommodations are made otherwise
the test instrument has no visibility as
to how the logic of the website or API
is implemented all that is known is the
input and the output
thus testing is conducted according to
these criteria
software testing levels there are four
levels of software testing let's take a
look at each unit testing is a dynamic
test that exercises a unit of code
typically a function the current trend
in testing is that developers write the
unit tests for their code they are the
ones that know the code best and are
responsible for making sure that the
code they write meets the defined
requirements integration testing is the
practice of ensuring that all the
components that the various developers
are writing work together according to
requirements and cause no side effects
typically integration testing is
performed upon the code base in the
common repository branch into which the
code from all developers is merged
system testing ensures that the code
overall meets the businesses
requirements system testing has a very
broad scope this includes not only
ensuring that the code meets the
predefined logical requirements but also
that the code interacts properly with
the other systems it's intended to
service during system testing engineers
observe code performance in terms of CPU
memory and storage behavior also system
testing observes network operations as
well remember in system testing
computing environment is just as
important as the software itself finally
operational acceptance testing is
conducted just before the code is about
to be released to end-users this testing
is also known as UAT
user acceptance testing in this phase of
testing non-technical personnel internal
and many times customers use the
software to make sure that it meets the
expectations at hand
popular software testing techniques
there are many techniques used to test
software some of the more popular are a
be testing usability and security
testing continuous testing functional
versus non functional testing alpha
testing beta testing regression testing
and smoke and sanity testing let's take
a look at each
hey be testing is the technique of
releasing a feature to a small audience
of users and then increasing the number
of users over time for example a company
will create a clone of the product code
including a new future and release it to
a set of servers bound to a specific
load balancer IP address the website
will be configured to route every tenth
request to the servers with a new
feature if the feature proves successful
traffic is increased to every fifth
request and then to every other request
however if something goes wrong the
routing to the new feature is terminated
ap testing is intended to let users
perform some degree of real-world
testing without putting the whole site
at risk
usability and security testing usability
testing is intended to determine how
easy the code is to use the scope of
usability testing is typically for those
features that require direct human
interaction usability testing goes
beyond just testing the graphical user
interface of a product in fact usability
testing api's is becoming a growing
concern and testing circles for example
human factors and usability test
engineers want to know how long it takes
for an engineer to figure out how to use
a given API is the documentation clear
are the error messages informative do
the API responses make sense these are
all questions that are answered
quantifiably on usability testing
security testing is concerned that the
code is safe to use and that it does not
cause critical harm to the system when
running this means that it's not taking
on permissions beyond the scope that's
needed it means that the code is not
behaving like a bad actor also security
testing is about making sure that bad
actors cannot get to the overall system
and do harm penetration tests also known
as pen tests are a type of test that is
usually performed when doing security
testing pen tests make sure that no IP
addresses or ports are left open
unintentionally to the outside world it
also means that sites and services can
withstand denial of service attacks
continuous testing is the practice of
testing at regular short intervals
throughout the software development life
cycle typically tests are conducted
automatically in response to an event in
the software development lifecycle for
example when a developer commits code to
a release branch or when a merge is
conducted into the overall codebase also
testing is done automatically on new
environments as they are provisioned the
overall intention of continuous testing
is to test early and test often
functional versus non functional testing
functional testing is intended to make
sure that code logic works as expected
that no side effects are incurred
functional testing is about ensuring
that code behaves according to
requirements non-functional testing
occurs at the system level
non-functional testing is concerned
about how the entire system works for
example non-functional testing is
concerned with network latency disk i/o
and fail safety
alpha testing is the practice of
releasing code that is considered just
good enough for the end users to
exercise it's expected to be buggy the
hope is that by reducing code to a lot
of users performing a variety of use
cases that issues not picked up an
internal testing will be uncovered beta
testing is the phase after alpha testing
when having fix issues uncovered by
users previously in alpha testing the
code is considered to be a release
candidate if all goes well in beta
testing the code will be given a release
version number deployed and supported
accordingly in beta testing the code is
expected to have a minimal amount of
bugs that need to be remedied
regression testing is the practice of
making sure that code that is about to
be released is operational and does not
break code in other parts of the system
a regression test a system-wide
regression testing is important because
otherwise it's quite possible to
introduce intended fixes into a system
that actually create more problems than
they solve
smoked insanity testing is a testing
regimen that's intended to check that
the most obvious parts of the system
work typically in smoke testing a tester
or the automated equivalent will log
into the system perform a few tasks and
then make sure all as well smoke and
sanity tests are intended to be fast and
just good enough to make sure that
there's nothing dramatically wrong with
the system
automation testing frameworks
test-driven development teams rely on
automated testing a testing framework is
used to write test cases and continuous
integration software or run use test
cases automatically a well-developed
testing framework or an integrated
development environment also known as an
IDE can be used to run the test scripts
some examples of automation testing
frameworks are loadrunner selenium and
test ng which is supported by maven
Jenkins has a number of plugins that
support automated testing IBM supports
automated testing for mobile devices and
there's the tried-and-true automated
testing tool for Java Jayne
automation testing frameworks there are
a number of types of automation testing
frameworks for example number one a
meaning of script ephemeral which is
also known as a Corbin playback you use
the framework complete test steps that
get executed in sequence for example
having the test tool fill in data in a
form on a web page and then verify the
results a typical linear scripting
framework is selenium number two hybrid
test automation framework that's one
where you use a combination of two or
more frameworks number three
keyword-driven testing keyword-driven
testing as a software testing
methodology that uses keywords or action
words to symbolize a functionality to be
tested for example consider the keywords
log in and log out these keywords will
be associated with tasks to execute the
keyword to task Association is usually
stored in an Excel spreadsheet or a
database
automated tests will go and look up on
the keyword and then do the associated
tasks keyword-driven testing frameworks
separate the test creation process into
two distinct stages of design and
development stage and an execution stage
number for data-driven testing
frameworks data clipping testing
frameworks is one which test scripts run
dynamically using predefined data sets
from some sort of data store such as a
database or an Excel spreadsheet for
example a data driven test is designed
to enter and validate name and address
information into a form and will use
data that's stored in the database
automatically a testing framework is
connected directly to the database and
data entry and validation occurs
automatically within the test no human
intervention is required number five a
modular testing framework is one in
which tests are organized into distinct
modules the benefit of a modular testing
framework is
encapsulation it provides makes updating
and extending and given module easier
and that the risk and concurrent side
effects is reduced you can think of a
modular testing firm work as one that
supports the concept of test Suites
where each suite contains one or many
tests as well as common setup and
teardown processes that can be applied
to all tests in the suite j-unit is an
example of a modular testing framework
number six behavior driven development
behavior driven development also known
as BDD focuses more on making sure the
software does what it's supposed to do
as opposed to worrying about how it does
it BDD tools tend to use natural
language constructs that are similar to
English like sentences for example in
BDD a common way to express an assertion
mister I'd expect check box 1 to be true
or the variable X should equal 4 EDD is
particularly effective when business
personnel are part of the development
team BDD allows more people even loans
without a programming background to
participate in test design
popular testing tools so Qi is an
open-source web service testing
application for service-oriented
architectures and restful api s robot
framework is a keyword-driven testing
framework that uses tabular test data
syntax
popular testing tools r-spec is a
domain-specific testing tool to test
Ruby code it's a behavior driven
development framework that's used in the
production of applications eggplant
functional is a black box GUI testing
automation tool which uses intelligent
image recognition algorithms to monitor
the display being tested it's used for
mobile testing cross-platform testing
and performance testing popular testing
tools mocha is a JavaScript test
framework for nodejs programs its
features are browser support
asynchronous testing test coverage
reports and news of any assertion
library jasmine is also an open source
testing framework for JavaScript
it supports asynchronous testing the use
of spies for implementing test doubles
and testing of front-end code through a
front-end extension
test-driven development approaches NJ
unified overview of test-driven
development test-driven development is a
software development process it depends
on the repetition of testing within
short development cycles requirements
are converted into test cases and then
the software is improved to pass new
tests developers apply the concept to
improve and debug legacy code developed
in older techniques test-driven
development also known as TDD is based
on a simple principle their principle is
that the test that describes the
behavior of the soft earth we developed
is written before creating the code
itself operationally this means that if
I am to write a function imagine get
winner I write the test for that
function before actually writing the
code for the function the developer
starts with a failing test and then gets
it to pass
test-driven development cycle one add
the test or you can also say create the
test to check that the new test fails
three write the code that gets the test
to pass four run the test five refactor
the code if necessary and then six
repeat the process again
test-driven development advantages there
are many advantages to taking a
test-driven development approach to the
software development lifecycle the
biggest advantages are fast feedback
developers are always running tests
against the code even before commits are
made to source control thus the feedback
loop is immediate creation of detailed
specification developers need a detailed
understanding of how the code being
written is supposed to behave in order
to write the test that's the starting
point of the development process thus
detailed specification is critical less
rework when the tests actually reflect
the behavior under development less
rework is required downstream in the
software development process less
debugging desired behavior has already
been established in the tests that need
to pass thus developers do most of the
initial debugging in the development
stage not later on in downstream
processes vas identification of errors
the initial tests reveal errors in code
as the code is being written testing
first makes the errors of peer at
development time not later on creation
of solid code the tests that the code
must satisfy exist first thus the code
being written is by nature more accurate
however in order to maintain a high
degree of accuracy developers must write
not only test cases that ensure the code
works in what is called a happy path
execution that's when things are going
the way expected but also developers
need to write unhappy Pat tests that
ensure that the code errors out in a way
that is expected and graceful clear
interface in order for the tests to be
accurate the interfaces that the code
exposes must be clear maintainable and
flexible test written before coding
takes place serve as a continued
in reference to determine code integrity
developers that follow TDD tend to run
all the tests in the codebase upon
initial check out from the source
control management system running all
the tests first informs a developer that
the codebase is sound and that he or she
can add new code and a way that does not
create side-effects failing tests
indicate that the codebase is out of
sync being able to determine the health
of the code on check out by running the
tests associated with the code first
makes it a lot easier to maintain the
code overall faster time-to-market the
practice of test first reduces all
development time having a developer
fixed code that he or she knows is a
faster process than having someone
further down the line in the development
process address issues fast resolution
of issues means faster time-to-market
less development cost a rule of thumb is
the most cost effective place to conduct
testing is to push testing activity as
close to the developer as possible
test-driven development is all about
having developers do more testing and
addressing issues raised when testing
hence the cost of development is reduced
provided the test coverage of the code
is comprehensive improved quality is by
nature built into the TDD process
increase in programmers productivity
having developers ensure the code as it
is being written takes a lot less time
than sending the code through the
software development process untested
only to have it returned to the
developer for remedy when the code is
found faulty fewer bugs as mentioned
earlier improved quality is by nature
built into the TDD process hence fewer
bugs simplification of code developers
only write the code that's needed to get
the test to pass nothing more nothing
less
as a result the code tends to be simpler
you
more elegant adaptability test-driven
development to be applied to any
development environment from COBOL to
Java to more modern languages such as
goal-line TDD is about the practice not
about a particular programming language
in TDD the motto is test first test
often and write only as much code as is
needed to get the test to pass
overview of J unit J unit is a unit
testing framework for the java
programming language over 10,000 Java
projects have used j unit as an external
library it's the first option that many
developers use for testing java
applications
advantages of j-unit there are many
advantages for using j-unit as the go-to
tool and a test-driven development
process let's take a look at some of the
advantages in j-unit the server
requirement is eliminated for testing
web applications it's a simple framework
for writing automated tests je unit has
a hierarchical structure program code
can be tested as a single unit or
multiple units je unit provides a
text-based command line and graphical
test reporting mechanism and finally je
unit supports test assertions and
immediate test reporting
Java a programming language the building
blocks of Java are standard to any
object-oriented programming language
let's take a look at the building blocks
abstraction Java allows programmers to
create interfaces and abstract classes
that serve as templates from which other
classes can be derived encapsulation a
class is the key building block of Java
behavior that is of concern only to the
class is encapsulated as private code
code that's to be used by consumers of
the class as made public
encapsulation promotes reuse and that
changes can be made to private code
without affecting consumers of the class
polymorphism Java supports polymorphism
this means that parameters can be added
to a function and thus extend new
behavior to the function in other words
a function can behave in many different
ways based on the number and type of
parameters passed to it inheritance
Java supports inheritance developers can
create new classes that are derived from
other classes a new class will get all
the properties and functions of the
parent class automatically inheritance
promotes code reuse significantly
j-unit 5-wood Java Jana five plus Java
requires that certain software be
available to design and to run tests the
software required is Java SE Java 8 or
higher
klipsch ide and the j-unit library
assisted practice test-driven
development approach with JUnit 5
you are given a project to demonstrate
the test-driven development approach
using j unit 5 and java as a programming
language hi so let's get started with
lab 4.1 test-driven development with j
unit 5 the objective of this lab is to
show you how to create a set of unit
tests in the Eclipse integrated
development environment and run those
unit tests under J unit 5 Eclipse is
already installed Auld in your classroom
virtual machine however if you want to
run the labs on your own computer you
can easily download eclipse from
eclipse.org now the first thing we need
to do is to create a working directory
for this lab in the terminal window of
your classroom virtual machine go to the
command line and type make their space
lab dot 4.1 hit the enter key this
creates the directory next let's
navigate into the directory by typing CD
space lab dot 4.1 and strike the Enter
key we type the Linux command clear to
clear the screen so that we can have an
uncluttered view of the work we're going
to do the code we're going to test is
already out on the simply learn github
repository so all we need to do is to
clone that code down into the classroom
virtual machine
at the command line of the classroom
virtual machine terminal window we type
get space clone space HTTP colon slash
slash github.com slash simply learn
DevOps official slash lesson - 0 4 - J
unit TDD dot GI T this is the get file
for the simply learn github repository
dedicated to this lab we strike the
enter key and the cloning process begins
let's confirm that the cloning process
worked at the command line we type the
Linux command LS and notice there is a
directory lesson - 0 4 - J unit EDD this
directory was created by the get cloning
process the directory contains the
source code we're going to use any clips
in this lab before we go on let's enter
the Linux command PWD present working
directory take note that we are in the
slash home slash Ubuntu slash lab dot
4.1 directory this is the directory
we're going to use once we're in Eclipse
we go over to the running instance of
Eclipse in our classroom virtual machine
you can see that Eclipse has no projects
loaded into it now we're going to load
in the code we downloaded from github we
click on the file menu in Eclipse and
from the file drop-down we select open
projects from filesystem Eclipse
displays the import projects dialog we
click the directory button on the upper
right hand side of the dialog we are
presented with the filesystem for the
classroom virtual
machine we select the folder lab 4.1 and
inside of that folder you'll see another
folder marked lesson - 0 4 - J unit TDD
that's the code we downloaded from
github we click on the ok button on the
lower right of the filesystem dialog
then we're back to the import projects
dialog notice that the import source is
now the J unit TDD folder we click the
finish button on the lower right of the
import projects dialog the project
appears in the Eclipse IDE notice on the
left and the project Explorer we can see
the file system for the project we click
on the down arrow and we see that there
is indeed a packaged comedy DJ unit Java
we click the down arrow and we can see
all the files in that package the files
are add java maths java and subtract
java we double click on the file maths
to open it up in the eclipse text editor
notice the class maths has two methods
add and subtract the method add
implements the add interface to find an
add Java and the method subtract
implements the subtract interface
defined and subtract Java now we're
going to create AJ unit 5 test case that
exercises the method add and the method
subtract we right click on math Java
from the drop down we select new and
from that drop down we select J unit
test case Eclipse displays the dialog
ooh j-unit test case notice that by
default eclipse wants to store the unit
test file into the same folder as the
source code this really isn't good
business what we're going to do instead
is to create a separate directory for
our tests we close the J unit test case
dialog we return to the project Explorer
on the left side of Eclipse and then we
right-click on the root of the project
tree TDD without j-unit we right-click
on new in the drop-down that appears and
then select source folder from the next
drop-down that appears Eclipse displays
the new source folder in the folder
named textbox
we enter test SRC then we click the
finish button on the lower right of the
dialog take a look in the Eclipse IDE on
the left side notice the package
Explorer now displays the folder test
source now it's time to create a j-unit
test case for maths java we right-click
on the file maths Java and select new
from the drop-down and then from that
drop-down select j-unit test case the
new j-unit test case dialog appears
start editorial comment editor please
notice that at timestamp 4 : 14 that the
new unit the new j-unit test case dialog
appears please put a freeze-frame here
as I need to explain the various fields
in the dialog and editorial comment
notice there are three text boxes we
want to pay attention to there is the
source folder at the top package and
the directory in the source folder
textbox is pointing to the source code
directory for the project this isn't
what we want we want the source folder
to be the directory test source that we
just created
also notice going down to the name
textbox that Eclipse has assigned a
default name to the test file and that
the fault name is maths test that's okay
the important thing to understand here
is that we need to change the source
folder to the directory test source to
change the directory we click the Browse
button to the right of the source folder
text box the source folder selection
dialog appears we select test source
from the dialog and then click the ok
button then in the test case dialog we
click the check boxes for our setup and
teardown clicking these check boxes will
insert setup and teardown methods into
the test case start editorial comment
editor we might have to put a
freeze-frame in time stamp 4 : 23
because I need to describe what setup
and teardown behaviors are and editorial
comment now what the setup method does
is it provides preliminary behavior that
gets run before the test happens tear
down is the behavior that gets run after
the test happens so for example if you
had to do a database setup you would put
the database setup in this setup method
and then if you wanted to disconnect
from the database you would put the
disconnection behavior in the teardown
method begin editorial comment editor
we're going to need a freeze-frame
a timestamp for call
29 so that I can explain why we're
skipping adding the J unit 5 library
temporarily and editorial comment
next Eclipse will want us to add the J
unit 5 library but before we do that we
have to do some other things with the
test configuration we click the cancel
button to skip adding the J unit 5
library temporarily we're going to get
back to that we're presented with a
dialog that asks us to select the
methods we want to test and we're going
to select mavs add and subtract we click
the finish button the dialog asking us
to add the J unit 5 library reappears so
we're going to select add J unit 5 and
then we're going to click the ok button
take a look at the project Explorer pane
on the left side of the Eclipse IDE
notice that the J unit 5 library is
indeed installed now also when we double
click on the file maths test out Java
you can see that the file appears in the
eclipse code editor notice that there's
a set up method a teardown method and
also a test add and a test subtract
method test add and test subtract are
the tests we're going to run to run the
test we right-click on the file maths
test Java and from the drop down select
run as and then select J unit tests the
J unit tests run but they fail take a
look at the left side of the Eclipse IDE
notice the red bar this indicates that
tests have failed and then if you look
in the failures text box you'll see that
indeed two tests have failed take a look
at the test add and test subtract
methods in the eclipse code editor
notice that by default they're given a
fail state you can see it says fail not
yet implemented our work now is to get
the tests
to pass now we're going to write some
code in the file maths test a Java
we create a private member variable and
we type private maths space class under
test semicolon okay so our private
member variable is class under test in
the setup method we type class under
test equal new maths what we've done is
created an instance of the maths class
that is visible throughout the test case
next we'll put test behavior in the
method test add let's recap the
important steps assisted practice
guidelines to demonstrate the usage of
j-unit 500 Java number one download Java
eight or a newer version and setup the
environment variables required number
two download Eclipse from the official
Eclipse site number three create a new
Java project in Eclipse
number four create two classes one to
add and another to subtract numbers
number five generate the J unit test
files for each class add the files in a
different source directory for better
indentation number six confirm that
Eclipse has added to J unit five library
to the build path number seven confirmed
that the test cases have failed and the
error logs are available in the failure
trace section in Eclipse
number eight rerun the test cases and
confirm that the tests have run
successfully without any error or
warning logs in the failure trace
behavior driven development principles
cucumber and it's applications
overview of behavior driven development
behavior driven development is an
extension of test-driven development
behavior driven development also known
as BDD focuses on where to start in the
process what to test and what not to
test how much to test and one go what to
name the tests and also how to
understand test failures behavior driven
development principles the first
principle is to define a test set for
the first unit second make the tests
fail third implement the unit and fourth
verify the implementation of the unit
that makes the test succeed in addition
to the guiding principles of BDD a key
concept of behavior driven development
is that software development needs to be
managed from both business and technical
perspectives
thus t2 BDD is the domain-specific
language also known as the DSL the DSL
describes those entities and processes
that are specific to the domain for
which the software is being developed
for example software being developed for
the medical industry will have a DSL
that contains the terms and by
association the software abstractions
that describe the medical domain if the
software is being developed for the
financial industry the terms and
software entities will describe those
and a decent processes associated with
finance all development takes place with
a DSL as the main means of expression
BDD is intended to take advantage of the
DSL to make mappings of business
requirements to test assertions a direct
Association thus many BDD tools provide
test expressions that appear as
assertions made in natural language for
example the assertion expect variable S
to be a string the focus of BDD is to
make it so that all members of the
development team
business and technical personnel alike
can serve as active empowered
contributors overview of cucumber
cucumber is a software tool for testing
other software by running automated
acceptance tests written using a
behavior driven development approach the
tool allows the execution of feature
documentation written in business facing
text cucumber uses the gherkin language
to define test cases it's designed to be
non-technical and human readable
cucumber collectively describes use
cases related to the software system
gherkin a language for cucumber gherkin
is a set of grammar rules that
structures the plaintext the cucumber to
understand it serves multiple purposes
gherkin provides unambiguous executable
specification automated testing and
documentation about the system's actual
behavior
gherkin keywords each line of the script
must start with a gherkin keyword
followed by any relevant text the
primary keywords are future scenario
given when then and but that mean steps
background scenario outline and examples
the secondary keywords are defined using
the following symbols along with text
quotation marks surrounding text for
docstring the pipe symbol for data
tables the @ sign for tags and the hash
or pound sign which indicates comments
tools for cucumber cucumber is supported
by a number of code editors ID ease and
development frameworks for example for
supported code editors there's atom
textmate which is a Mac OS product and
Visual Studio code which is available in
Windows Mac OS and Linux supported IDE
SR IntelliJ and Eclipse and supported
build tools are Apache maven Gradle and
rate cucumber with Java in order to run
cucumber and Java there are certain
software requirements that need to be
satisfied
these are Java SC up to Java 8 be
careful Java 9 and higher versions are
not supported yet
maven version 3.3 point 1 or higher the
IntelliJ IDE with the cucumber for Java
plug-in installed and cucumber Eclipse
which is an alternative for IntelliJ
cucumber with JavaScript in order to use
cucumber with JavaScript there's certain
software that's required the software is
no js' which is a JavaScript runtime
engine a text editor such as Adam or our
Visual Studio code or textmate which is
only available for mac users
cucumber with ruby in order to run
cucumber with Ruby you're going to need
certain software the required software
is Ruby bundler and a text editor
cucumber with Kotlin in order to run
cucumber with Kotlin you're going to
need to make sure that required software
is installed the required software is
Java SE version 8 again be careful Java
9 and higher versions are not yet
supported for cucumber maven version 3.3
point 1 or higher the IntelliJ IDE with
the cucumber for Java plugin installed
also you need to make sure that the
IntelliJ IDE has the Kotlin plug-in
installed and also you can use cucumber
Eclipse with Kotlin Eclipse which is an
alternative to IntelliJ assisted
practice behavior driven development
approach with cucumber problem statement
you are given a project to demonstrate
the behavior driven development approach
using cucumber and JavaScript as a
language welcome to lab 4.2 installing
cucumber in this lesson we're going to
install nodejs and p.m. the node package
manager Visual Studio code then we're
going to take a brief introductory
overview of cucumber the first step is
to install node.js one way to install
nodejs is to go to the website at nodejs
org and download it directly using the
download page another way to install
nodejs is at the command line in a
terminal window we go to a terminal
window in your classroom virtual machine
then at the command line we type sudo
space apt - get space update
this will do a package update before we
install nodejs
once the update completes we use the
Linux command clear at the command line
to clear the screen now we'll install
nodejs using apt-get at the command line
we type sudo space apt - g-e-t apt-get
space install space
node J s and then we hit the enter key
the installation process will start then
we strike the Y key on the keyboard to
continue the installation to confirm
that node is installed we type at the
command line no space - V hmm that's
strange at the command-line we're
getting a message saying the program
node is currently not installed you can
install it by typing and there's the
command so let's type that command we'll
type at the command line sudo space apt
space install space node J s - legacy
okay that works so let's check the
version of node at the command-line we
type node space - V and the version v4
dot 2.6 is displayed now be advised when
you install node you'll probably get a
higher version number and that's okay
because we want to stay up to date with
the current version but in this case
we're going to go with the version of
this installation now let's check to see
if the node package manager and PM is
installed at the command line we type
NPM space - V notice the output the
program NPM is currently not installed
you can install it by typing and there's
the command so that's what we'll do at
the command line we type sudo space apt
space install space NPM the installation
process starts then we strike the Y key
on the keyboard to continue with the
installation
let's check the version of NPM at the
command line we type NPM space - V and
notice we get version 3.5 - now again
when you install NPM you're probably
going to get a higher version number
because by default
to get or apt install will always find
the latest version of a piece of
software to install we type the Linux
command clear to clear the screen now we
need to go to the website for Visual
Studio code or what's also called vs
code so in the browser we type code dot
visual studio comm slash download we
click on the button dot DB to download
the Debian Ubuntu package of Visual
Studio code
remember your classroom virtual machine
is running the Ubuntu operating system
the reason we're downloading Visual
Studio code is that we need the vs code
integrated development environment in
order to run cucumber we type LS to find
the location of the downloads directory
then we type CD downloads we type LS to
see if the code download has completed
yet well it hasn't let's wait a moment
again we type LS to see if the vs code
is downloaded notice on the left hand
side of the screen there is a file code
underscore one - 302 - 1 5 and a whole
lot of numbers dot de Bie this is the vs
code download now remember when you do
this process you might get a higher
version number because the download is
going to get the latest version now we
need to extract the vs code application
files from the dot de Bie file at the
command line we type sudo space d PKG
space minus i space and the file name of
the vs code DB file then we hit enter
the unpacking process begins once the
download is complete we go to the
applications tab
in our classroom virtual machine on the
upper left of our screen we click the
applications tab and a drop-down appears
we go to the development menu item in
the drop down we click the item
development in the drop down list you'll
notice that a sub-item Visual Studio
code appears we click the Visual Studio
code menu item if indeed you don't see
the Visual Studio code menu item in the
drop down list you might have to go back
and try to reinstall Visual Studio again
anyway if indeed the program is
installed successfully when you click
the menu item visual studio code the
application will start up great so
Visual Studio is successfully running
now we need to go back to the terminal
window in our classroom virtual machine
and make a directory for our cucumber
work at the command line
we type mkdir dot 2 and then we hit the
enter key now we navigate to the folder
we just created so we type CD space lab
4.2 and hit the enter key next we need
to create a working directory for our
cucumber work so at the command line we
type MK dar space hello
cucumber h-e-l-l-o CUC um ER then we
strike the Enter key now we navigate to
the working directory by typing CD space
hello cucumber we go back to the visual
studio code application we go to the
file menu and click on the menu item
open folder the open folder dialog
appears in the open folder
we click on lab 4.2 and then the folder
hello cucumber we click the ok button in
the lower right hand corner of the open
folder dialog the IDE displays the hello
cucumber directory we click the maximize
button in the upper right side of the
visual studio code window to get a
better view we're going to open the
terminal window in Visual Studio code in
the visual studio menu bar we click the
View tab and you'll see a drop-down
appear we scroll down and click the menu
item terminal the terminal pane appears
in the visual studio code IDE in the
lower part of the main window we're
going to create a no js' project using
the terminal window in Visual Studio
code in the lower pane we type NPM space
in it - - ye s this creates a no js'
project with a default package dot JSON
file now we need to make an entry in the
package dot JSON file for cucumber and
also install the cucumber nodejs modules
to do this at the command line in the
visual studio code window we type NPM
space install space cucumber space - -
save - dev and we strike the enter key -
- save - dev tells the NPM package
installer to make an entry for cucumber
in the development node of package.json
also NPM will install the node package
for cucumber now what's interesting is
once cucumber is in package JSON the
only thing another developer needs to do
to install the project is to type NPM
install at the command line
then the NPM package manager is smart
enough to inspect package JSON and
install all the node modules listed you
can see NPM starting to install the node
modules for cucumber upon completion of
the installation of the node modules for
cucumber you'll see a listing of the
modules dependencies in a tree in the
terminal window of vs code cucumber
requires that we create a folder named
features we're going to use the terminal
window in Visual Studio code to create
that directory in the terminal window of
Visual Studio code we type the command
line instructions m'kay der space
features we navigate to the features
folder by typing CD space features and
then striking the Enter key next we need
to create another folder named steps in
the terminal window of visual studio
code we type mk2 space steps and strike
the enter key on our keyboard when you
look at the vertical Explorer pane on
the left hand side of the visual studio
code window you'll notice that there's a
folder named features and a subfolder
named steps now we need to create a file
cucumber j/s to store default
configuration settings we navigate to
the root of the project folder
so we type CD space lab 4.2 and we
strike the enter key then in the visual
studio code terminal we type at the
command line CD hello
cucumber we're in the root directory of
the hello cucumber project now we need
to create the file cucumber J s at the
command line in the terminal window of
visual studio code we type touch space
cucumber dot J s this creates an empty
file named cucumber dot J s now we need
to export the default settings in the
vertical Explorer panel on the left side
of the visual studio code window we
select the file cucumber J s this will
open cucumber J s in the visual studio
code text editor we type the node j s
module export statement module dot
exports space and equal sign open and
close curly brackets within the curly
brackets we type default colon and a
pair of tick quotes tick quotes on a
u.s. keyboard can be found to the left
of the numeral 1 key within the tick
quotes we type - - format - options
space single quote left curly bracket
double quote snippet capital I lowercase
nter FAC e double quotes colon space
double quotes synchronous double quotes
right curly bracket single quote tick
right curly bracket now I know that's a
lot so pay close attention to the screen
and make sure you enter exactly what
you see now save the file we're going to
create a file named step def dot J s and
we're going to put it in the steps
directory so in Visual Studio code on
the left side Explorer pane we select
the steps folder with our mouse right
click and select new file we name the
file step def j s now click on the file
step J F to bring it up in the visual
studio code text editor once you see the
file click in the file and enter Const
space assert equals space require a
paren pair single quote assert single
quote semicolon
this tells node that we want to create
an instance of the assert object which
ships with the assert library which
ships with node in the file step def dot
j s next we want to tell node to use the
given when and then objects from within
cucumber in the editor we type Const
left bracket capital given comma capital
when comma then right curly bracket
equals require paren single quote
cucumber single quote and using the
brackets to extract variable names is
special to es6 if you're using s 5 this
probably won't work but under EF es6 you
can plot a number of objects from one
given library using the multiple
declaration within the curly bracket
technique ok don't forget to save the
file next we need to go and tell node
how to run a cucumber test so we go back
to package
JSON and then in the package adjacent
file which you'll see in the visual
studio code editor you'll see a scripts
node and beneath that a test node we
delete the default entry that NPM init
made in the test node of the
package.json file you can see it says
echo slash error no test specified and
an exit we're going to delete that so we
do and in its place we type cucumber -
j/s this is telling node to run the
command cucumber J s when it comes time
to run the test from the command line so
at the terminal window in Visual Studio
code on the lower part of the pane we
type NPM space test you can see that
cucumber responds with zero scenarios
and zero steps and this is okay because
we haven't written any tests and
cucumber yet we're gonna write tests in
the next lesson hi in this lab we're
going to create a cucumber test by first
writing a feature and scenario with
steps in a dot feature file using the
gherkin language gherkin is a
declarative language similar to yamo we
use gherkin to describe a feature and
then a scenario and then the given when
and then steps that need to be executed
within the cucumber test now remember
we're going to write the feature the
scenario and the test steps in gherkin
but what we're not going to write is the
java script that implements the steps
defined in the future file
thus the scenario and the steps are
undefined and the test will fail so to
make a long story short in cucumber
we're going to write an
to find test we're going to we're going
to write our cucumber scenario in the
Visual Studio code IDE we open the
Visual Studio code IDE by going to the
applications tab in our classroom
virtual machine we click the
applications tab and a menu drops down
from that menu we select the development
item and then the Visual Studio code
context item appears we click visual
studio code this will open up the vs
code IDE Visual Studio code opens we go
to the file menu and select the open
folder item the open folder dialog
appears we navigate to the folder lab
4.2 which is a project we made in the
last video then once in the folder lab
4.2 we select the folder hello cucumber
we click the ok button to open hello
cucumber in the visual studio code IDE
the open cucumber project opens in
Visual Studio code when you take a look
at the project Explorer on the left side
of the Visual Studio code IDE you'll
notice that the cucumber node module is
installed when we select the file index
J s you can see that it appears in the V
s code text editor in this case index
that j s is the entry point for the
cucumber node modules CLI library
cucumbers ships with a number of options
CLI which is the command-line interface
and also other libraries that you can
use directly as part of the testing
process the important thing to
understand about index KS again is that
it is the entry point for a module and
this is how we know we have cucumber
installed now let's see if we can get a
test run
in the terminal window of the vs code
IDE which is in the lower part of the
screen we type NPM space test and notice
that cucumber tries to run but it
reports that there are zero scenarios
and zero steps this makes sense because
we haven't written any scenario for the
test yet nor have we written the
implementation code behind it so let's
start at the beginning and write the
scenario we collapse the node modules
folder and navigate up to the features
folder and the hello cucumber project
now as you might remember from earlier
cucumber requires that we have a
features folder and that in the futures
folder there is a dot feature file and
also a folder step underscore
definitions the future file we're going
to create is name is underscore it
underscore capital Friday underscore yet
dot feature so in the Explorer window of
the vs code IDE on the left-hand side we
click on the futures folder and then we
click on the new file icon which is to
the right of the hello cucumber listing
in the project Explorer of visual studio
code a text box appears in the project
Explorer for the file and we type is
underscore it underscore capital F
Friday underscore yet dot feature this
feature file will describe the scenario
that cucumber is going to support now
it's time to write the feature in the
first line of the text editor we type
feature : is it Friday yet what a
question mark this is the feature
definition and the second line you put
an indent and then we write a
description the description is everybody
wants to know when it's Friday now be
advised
this description is arbitrary we can put
anything in there we want its purpose is
to provide descriptive text so that
people who are running the test and know
what it's about we skip a line and at
line four we enter the scenario so we
indent and then we type the word
scenario followed by a colon space and
then Sunday isn't Friday this is our
scenario we want to test in a behavior
driven manner that we can prove that
sunday isn't Friday next we need to
enter three steps given when and then
and these are fundamental to cucumber in
other words we're going to say given a
certain condition when this is in force
then this needs to happen
so let's write these steps first we
write the given step so we indent and
were the same indent level as scenario
we type given space
today is Sunday we enter another line
number six and at the same indent level
is given we type when space I asked
whether it's Friday yet that's the one
step then we enter another line and then
at line seven at the same indent level
as when we type then space I should be
told
quotation nope quotation so let's review
we've set up our feature then we've
defined the scenario we've written the
given step the one step and the then
step now let's run the test at the
terminal window in the vs code IDE we
type NPM space test this command runs
the test instruction we defined in the
last video in the package.json file the
test runs notice that the response is
that one scenario is undefined and that
three
steps are undefined and this makes sense
because we've written the scenario in
the future file but we haven't
implemented the actual test behavior in
JavaScript and that's to come in the
next video okay so let's do the lab
that's concerned with a scenario that's
going to fail and then pass in cucumber
the objective of this lab is to write a
cucumber test that supports a scenario
defined in a feature file begin editor
note editor
we need a freeze frame at timestamp 0 5
and editor note the cucumber test we're
gonna implement is based on the file is
it Friday yet dot feature as shown on
your screen the way that cucumber works
is that it will use the feature file to
define certain aspects of the behavior
test we're going to implement in the
future file there's a scenario describe
sunday isn't Friday and it's given a
given Clause today is Sunday and then
there's a one Clause I asked whether
it's Friday finally there's a then
Clause I should be told
nope so let's take a look at how to turn
this feature into a cucumber test in the
visual studio code IDE we go over to the
left the Explorer pane and we click on
the file step def CAS the file appears
in the visual studio code editor in the
main page notice please that the file
declare is a constant assert equals
require assert and the assert library is
built into nodejs
also the file declares three variables
given when then and those come from the
cucumber module which we installed
previously
in the code editor we write a function
is it Friday we add the parameter today
to the function we add the comment will
leave the implementation blank for now
now the given object takes a constructor
so we'll add one in the Visual Studio
code editor we add the constructor given
paren single quote today is sunday
single quote comma function paren set
curly brackets in the function body we
add the statement this dot today
equals single quote sunday single quote
sunday is a string that we're assigning
to the member variable this thought
today when is also an object that takes
a constructor the constructor takes two
parameters the condition string and a
function so we enter single quote I ask
whether it's Friday yet single quote
comma function parens curly brackets in
the function body
we had the statement this dot actual
answer equals is it Friday where is it
Friday is the function we've defined
previously we pass the parameter this
thought today into the function is it
Friday next we implement the then object
which is also a constructor we type
single quote I should be told
curly brackets string curly bracket
single quote where string is a format
parameter then we add the function
parameter we type function paren
expected answer paren curly brackets in
the body of the function we type the
statement a
dot equal paren this dot actual answer
comma expected answer paren semicolon
this statement asserts that the
condition we're testing for is actually
enforced that the actual answer equals
the expected answer now let's execute
the test in the visual studio code IDE
the terminal is in the lower pane at the
command line in the terminal we type NPM
space test where test is defined in the
package dot JSON file the cucumber test
runs and you can see it fails let's
review the test in the terminal given
today is Sunday when I ask whether it's
Friday yet I should be told nope but I'm
not told nope nothing happens
thus the test fails we clear the console
in Visual Studio code by typing the
Linux command clear at the command line
we edit the function is it Friday yet we
go to the function and we remove the
comment we placed there previously then
we type return space single quote nope
single quote semicolon thus whenever we
call the function is it Friday it will
return the string nope now we run the
test again in the terminal of Visual
Studio code this time the test passes
let's recap the important steps
assistant practice guidelines to
demonstrate the usage of cucumber number
one install nodejs
and NPM from the nodejs official website
number two open visual studio code and
check the version of node and NPM number
three create an empty cucumber project
folder number four add cucumber as a
development dependency to Visual Studio
code number five create a folder future
and in it create another subfolder steps
number six add the code to the
respective files seven verify cucumber
installation and eight confirm that all
the scenarios and steps have passed
key takeaways you are now able to
describe the benefits of traditional and
agile approaches to software testing you
can describe the levels and approaches
of software testing you can demonstrate
a test-driven development framework with
j-unit and finally you can demonstrate a
behavior driven development framework
with cucumber hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here